so all of us are dead is a new school
zombie show that's in a class of its own
the series is packed with amazing
character development tense action
scenes and a different take on the
zombie genre that breathes new life into
something that's been done to death
heavily inspired by properties like
trainer bissan and kingdom we watch as a
zombie plague makes its way through a
major city in korea and through the
season we follow several of the
survivors as they try and make their way
to a quarantined camp coming in at over
12 hours long it feels like a grueling
journey to get through that could have
been avoided if people just learn to
stay away from little hellish hamsters
however this series is definitely worth
watching and if you finished it then
this is the video for you throughout it
we're going to be breaking down the
ending and also discussing what we think
could be happening in season 2. there
will be heavy spoilers from here on out
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
it then going past this point would be a
grave mistake if you enjoy the video
then please use your brains and click
the thumbs up button along with a
subscribe to stay locked into the
channel without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into all of
us are dead okay so all of us are dead
primarily focuses on a group of students
that band together at their school in
order to survive a zombie outbreak
throughout the series we learned that
this was caused by the school science
teacher whose son was bullied so bad
that he attempted to give him a new way
to fight back the pair were both failed
by the school system that looked the
other way whilst bullies were allowed to
destroy someone's life and thus the
teacher tried to give his son something
that would even the odds however this
backfired and instead it created a
legion of the undead whilst the virus
itself mutated into two different types
firstly there was the more ravenous type
in which people completely lost all
control and they turn into flesh-eating
monsters intent on ripping you apart as
the military and government learn more
about the virus we discover that it
actually completely kills the carrier
and just stimulates their body basically
making their corpse move the variant to
this is 98 similar but the host retains
their consciousness and thus we get a
human zombie hybrid that appears fine
from the outside but they do hunger for
human flesh from time to time the idea
of a virus is laced throughout the show
and even in the title sequence we see
several of the undead laid out in a way
that's similar to how the disease is
shown in episode 9. like most korean
shows there's a lot of social commentary
and throughout the season we see vast
blankets of the public believing that
the outbreak is fake news we watch
quarantine zones being set up and even
get bullying metaphors laced throughout
the entire thing the latter of these
comes in the form of guinem a guy that
should have been killed for the mullet
alone in the series he ends up becoming
infected with the mutated version of the
virus and he attempts to track down his
bitter school rival chong san and the
other students that he's with among
cesar suyuk the leader that everyone
wishes they were in school namra the
class president that should be president
of the world on joe whose dad's a
firefighter desperately looking for her
and several others most of which get
picked off one by one queen am is
basically like the nemesis from resident
evil with a mullet and he stalks the
corridors looking for the group
desperate for revenge no matter how many
times they defeat him he always comes
back and during the series namra gets
infected with the same mutation that he
has this grants her increased strength
and power but like the rest of the
undead she too starts to yearn for human
flesh in the subplot the military
realized that the undead can be herded
by using the frequency of 24 kilohertz
and thus they put together a plan to
usher all of the zombies into a specific
area with drones they'll bomb the living
sorry dying hell out of them and
basically try and contain the virus as
much as possible this is inspired by the
final video left by the science teacher
in which he realizes that the only way
to destroy the virus is to wipe it out
completely obviously there wouldn't be
much tension if the school wasn't one of
the locations getting bombed and thus
there becomes somewhat of a race to get
out of dodge before school's out
[Music]
[Applause]
forever now towards the end of the
season the group raced to a construction
site right beside the school and it's at
this point that they're attacked by
guinam chung-sang gets bit and thus he
remains behind to buy this time in order
to escape the battle is as bloody as
you'd expect and it really sums up the
phrase an eye for an eye as they battle
it out the missiles start to bombard the
area and chung sign ends up taking
guinham down a half built elevator shaft
where the two both perish now i have
seen people online going back and forth
over whether cheong sang is actually
dead and i'm unsure too due to the
evidence that we get the first of which
comes when the pair both go down the
elevator shaft and we only see guinea's
body being obliterated in the fire i've
slowed down the footage so you can see
this happening but chiang sang does get
engulfed by it too however he doesn't
really get the orangey burn that guinam
does and his head can also still be seen
occurred at the end of the episode when
we close in on on joe's name badge and
you can also see a set of fingers
possibly belonging to the character
however in episode 12 we do see what
looks like his body along with several
others personally i think that the
character is likely dead but there are
several times throughout the season
where they imply that he's finished and
the next episode we learn that isn't the
case when looking for him namra says
that she can't smell anything which is a
line that is stuck in my head long after
finishing the season i think this could
have been done on purpose to give the
audience the idea that he might have
actually survived the encounter it's
pretty crazy if he did but at the end of
the season we do get lip service paid
towards other characters being out there
now this isn't me confirming whether
he's alive or not and in all honesty
like i said i'm not that sure myself i
think it does leave an opening for the
creative team to potentially bring him
back but the bombing itself was extreme
so if he doesn't return then at least he
went out with a bang
[Music]
now this causes so much pain that the
head of the military actually ends his
own life and it definitely feels like
this is a series that doesn't really
have any winners this is reflected in
several of the parents that die in order
to save their kids most notably on joe's
father nam soju now throughout the
series he makes a daring journey out of
the quarantined zone in order to save
his daughter just as he's reunited with
her he ends up sacrificing himself in
order to save her from being eaten by
zombies it's a pretty devastating gut
punch but he doesn't die in vain as when
the students finally escape the school
they find ribbons amongst the trees that
lead them somewhat to safety eventually
the group make it to young dung but
they're not out of the woods yet and we
get one final death in woojin a kid who
saves his badass sister with a bow she's
so cool isn't she she she is cool to be
fair now jin ends up turning but
unfortunately his sister can't bring
herself to kill him and thus namra steps
in in order to break his neck this sets
off hari but it also causes urges within
namra to feed on her flesh anjo even
offers herself up as a meal but namra
decides to stay in control and then she
makes a choice to remain behind whilst
the group go into the quarantine zone
eventually they make it but they're put
in prison and interrogated over what
they know of the events they've been
through hell which has really matured
them and in the end they stand up for
themselves and refuse to cooperate this
was a government that left them behind
to die on the off chance that they were
infected and thus they stand firm in
their stents over time as the virus dies
down things start to open up once more
and we get a time jump of four months in
which the group are finally freed this
is along with several of the other
characters that we met throughout the
series who somewhat get a happy ending
as a precaution though the residents of
the area are kept in quarantine whilst
career and the rest of the world come to
grips with what happened people have had
their homes and lives destroyed over
something that could have been prevented
had more care being given at a human
level now in the aftermath we follow on
joe as she sneaks out of the compound
one night and during this journey she
notices a fire on the school roof namra
said that if they ever met again that
they should have a campfire and after
telling su yuk the rest of the survivors
go back into the restricted zone
searching for their friend
upon huddling together on the roof they
come across namra and it's a pretty
pretty pretty heartfelt reunion now it
brings everything together and though
the groups still refer to her as their
prez they know that they can't be
together namra says that she's neither
human or a monster and though they want
her to stay with them she says that
she's found a new purpose now the series
is very much a coming-of-age story in
which our characters mature and grow as
people namra says that it's sort of like
being between a child and an adult which
is of course reflected in the teenagers
themselves anja at one point even says
that she'll never help adults again and
in some ways the group are something new
themselves much like the hybrids they've
seen the ugly side of society and though
they will live among it it's unlikely
that they'll ever truly feel part of it
again namra says that she wants to help
the others like her that have been
forced to live in restricted zones and
she leaps off into the night sky and
probably a second season
it's been trending all weekend now going
forward i do think that we will probably
follow namra on the most part as she
starts to survey the area i think that
most of the characters will return to
somewhat normality after their feed from
quarantine but with the virus still
being out there there is the possibility
that it could spread once more like all
humans the hybrids will have their own
desires and aims and there may even be
some that see the undead is the future
in the likes of guinea we saw that he
actually relished living in the
hellscape and thus there might be other
characters who wish to infect people so
that they can rule there's definitely a
lot of possibilities and who knows the
need to eat may even have proven too
much for namra she does look somewhat
healed in this final scene and therefore
it is possible that she could have eaten
beyond this though she might have found
a way to consume normal food and be
sustaining herself of this namra in the
end very much represents what the
teacher wanted his son to be and in many
ways she is now a superhero she's very
much the end goal of the virus and has
likely found a way to heal without
having the insatiable hunger that is a
downside of being infected there's lots
of questions that could be answered in
the second season but with her and the
hybrids being carriers i still think
it's through them that the virus will
spread once more the characters did a
good job of keeping it contained in the
series but i'd love to see it
potentially even start to corrupt others
hell it might not even be the hybrids
that cause the issues and it could be
the humans that end up resenting those
that live in the restricted zones the
war very much divides the societies and
this may cause a divide in which the
regular humans wish to take back the
area and thus oust the hybrids it's
clear that the students don't want to
work with the uninfected as they've seen
that when push comes to shove they
completely disregard their lives
therefore they might even travel to the
other side and end up living with namra
and the other hybrids there's a lot of
things that could happen going forward
and as for my thoughts on the series
though i thought it was a little long at
points i did really enjoy it rocking in
at 12 hours makes it one of the longer
shows on netflix and there are certain
elements and scenes that i think could
have been cut to make it a better paced
show saying all that though once you're
in this world you really don't want to
leave it and the action acting and
character development are really well
done you feel for all these characters
and it's gripping watching the series
play out as you start to lose some of
your favorite people korea continues to
knock it out of the park when it comes
to shows and there's a lot going on in
this i'd love to see developed in a
second season all of us are dead was
great and it gets an 8.5 out of 10. now
i'd of course love to hear your thoughts
on the show so make sure you comment
below and let me know if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of hellbound
which will be linked on screen right now
that's another korean classic that's got
a supernatural element to it and if
you've seen the show then it's
definitely worth checking that one out
too without the way thanks for sitting
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you in the next one take care peace